what would you say to people who are
trying to escape this curse of
mediocrity well if you're satisfied with
it in some fundamental sense there's
something to be said I suppose for
Walling off a private space for yourself
if you can maintain it and detaching
yourself to some degree from the
Troubles of the world and maintaining
your own little private Garden the
problem with that is the snakes tend to
seep in from the outside I don't believe
it's really possible because you can't
have a Walled Garden independently of
the health of the broader Society I
think for the most part it's people that
have become sedated you know they've
forgotten their dreams but they've
forgotten that they've forgotten them
and this story really hit me so during
the pandemic I have a friend that's a
barber Bob is shut down for a long
period of time and he got a job at
supermarket stacking shelves and asked
him and how are you finding the new job
actually don't mind the work but man I
miss being good at something people need
the opportunity to be good at something
so then you might ask yourself well
what's the best antidote to the
discomfort of life and you might say
well it's Comfort a better antidote is
something like Adventure to Excellence
and that's far better antidote to
suffering than the mere absence of
suffering